في الاثناء شيعه اهالي غزه شهداء القصف
الاسرائيلي على القطاع وبينهم ثلاثه قاده
في حركه الجهاد واربعه اطفال وخمس نساء
انطلقت الجثامين من المسجد العمري بعد
اداء صلاه الجنازه عليهم وسط حشودا غفيره
وكانت مسيره تحمل الجثامين جابت شوارع
المدينه بعد انطلاقها من مستشفى الشفاء في
المدينه وردد مشاركون في المسيره هتافات
تطالب بفصائل المقاومه بالرد السريع على
عدوان قوات الاحتلال الذي يستهدف منازل
قاده في سرايا القدس الجناح العسكري لحركه
الجهاد الاسلامي واغتلهم مع زوجاتهم وعدد
من ابنائهم
هذا وكان ابو حمزه الناطق العسكري باسمي
سرايا القدس الجناح العسكري لحركه الجهاد
الاسلامي قد اكد الالتزام بالواجب تجاه
الشهداء ومواجهه العدوان بكل اقدام واضاف
ابو حمزه في بيان المصور ان هذه المجازر
ستزيد الشعب الفلسطيني تمسكا بالمقاومه
حتى تحرير كل فلسطين
يا جماهير بن الصابر المرابط
اننا امام هذا العدوان البربري الظالم
نؤكد في سرايا القدس والمقاومه على ما يلي
اولا
ندعو جماهير شعبنا الى الصبر والصمود
والالتفاف حول المقاومه كخيار استراتيجي
لردع المحتل وصد العدوان ثانيا
ان هذه المجازر التي يرتكبها جيش الارهاب
الصهيوني
بحق مدنيين الابرياء في بيوتهم
ستزيد شعبنا الباسل
تمسكا بالمقاومه حتى تحرير فلسطين كل
فلسطين
ثالثا
نؤكد في سرايا القدس والمقاومه
اننا سنكون عند التزامنا وواجبنا اتجاه
الشهداء
وسنواجه العدوان بكل ثبات
واقدام بمشيئه الله وقوته